(gentle piano music)
- When I have the Henna crown on,
it's as if people don't see the sickness
as much as they do when
your head is just bald.
They just look and they see this
beautiful artwork, and it's empowering.
It's nice to feel almost normal again.
- My name is Sarah Walters, and I'm
a professional Henna artist.
The term, Henna Crown is
being used to describe
intricate Henna designs
that are applied to
the scalp following hair loss, um, typically,
so usually people will
refer to Henna crowns
as being applied to people
who've gone through chemo therapy.
I initially began doing
Henna crowns when my mom
asked me to do one for her friend,
who had recently lost her
hair during chemo therapy,
so I agreed to do it and it
was a wonderful experience.
From that point on, I knew that I wanted
to continue to offer crowns for people.
- My name's Vicki Sumner, and I
have stage four breast cancer.
Once cancer becomes stage four and
it travels to other
organs, it then becomes
a terminal diagnosis
and so everything we do,
from here, is just trying to stay alive.
- I'll probably start, you know, at the front,
maybe on this side or this side.
- I originally looked for a Henna crown
because I wanted to share
a message on my head.
The message on the back
says, Stage IV needs more.
Stage four breast cancer
needs more attention,
for years it's been sort
of swept under the rug,
nobody wanted to talk about it
because it's terminal cancer.
When I go in to get my Henna crown,
it is like a spa-like experience.
Sarah scents it with lavender
and it's calming and soothing
and sometimes I nod off a little bit.
It takes about an hour, hour and a half,
and it's just relaxing and you wake up
and see the beautiful artwork that
she's come up with when you're finished.
My daughter loves it when I come home
and I have the Henna, she's like,
“Oh, you got it again!"
- I think that everyone is
beautiful in their own way,
and I can see the beauty in these people
that come to me, wanting a crown,
because they're displaying a lot of
strength and resilience and fight.
At the same time, they're feeling
maybe a lack of confidence or, you know, discomfort
about the loss of their
hair and other things
that they're going through and
when the crown that I do for them,
gives them that boost of confidence,
it's just a really awesome feeling
because it does make them
feel a little more beautiful,
I think in some cases.
- So pretty.
- Yay!
I'm so glad you like it.
- I always believe that we should try to
make other people smile during the day
and that we should always do something
kind for the people around us.
Sarah's one of those people;
Sarah's one of those people
trying to make a small difference
to the people around her, by offering
the Henna crowns to people
suffering from cancer,
just makes the world a better place.
(lively music)